I was a gymnast for over ten years I was
a level training level 10 gymnast and I
had to quit recently cuz my back so
basically I've been friends with a few
people like I've been friends with chase
for a really long time now and I just
slowly became friends I think everyone
and then like when the whole idea was
playing out Thomas just telling me about
it he was like definitely like we want
you to be a part of it I would love to
feels like all my friends was like yes
for sure you ready to go home so like a
bunch of people in the house like they
do like dancing and stuff I do makeup
like I like when they were talking about
like how how long you takes to make a
video like somebody was taking me six
hours to make that and then I post and
like posting three times a day with
makeup I can't really do so but when I
like put all this effort into like
makeup looks I do like scary like acting
videos and stuff with it and like that
kind of took off and like no one else
here it really does makeup it's just
[Music]
so it's like we need you like that's a
whole different like realm of things so
basically for a basic like makeup video
I would do I'd find an audio
[Music]
and then whenever I do my makeup it's
kind of there cuz no one really asked me
like how like I put like thought into it
because I got usually there's a caption
that goes with the audio and then with
my makeup I can't do my makeup unless I
have a thought in my head of like
something that's like going on like with
me something sad anything I'll put it
all into like a look that's based off
the audio then I'll use it it's no
really knows like the backstory of like
my videos cuz I get this like personal
but like I just like put it out there
it's like show it through makeup and see
if anyone can like figure it out I have
no clue that's the thing I just like I
did it one time I was like doing my
makeup for an Instagram post I was like
based off of something I just like
recently happened and so then I put all
it like put it all on my face I was like
wait I could put this on tik-tok and do
it so I picked like an audio as then and
now instead of doing it that way I
flipped it and I find an audio cuz its
audios are kind of hard to find right
now cuz I feel like being over you so
I'm like really trying to like find a
good audios for makeup oh by the way if
you'd really like to know he went that
way so what I do is I find like I have
videos planned like for like my week
like I have a video and audio saved
right now I'm gonna do tonight which all
happens I like 3 a.m. because like
that's are all my thoughts like coming
in and so I like find the audio like a
week before and I just like listening to
it over and over again what am I gonna
do for it and then then I do the makeup
and then like the video doesn't tape it
doesn't take long to shoot the video
after I do the makeup so like the video
like comes like really quick I get it
take me 5 minutes to film a video but
the process before it's like hours
sometimes takes like two or three to do
a retake yeah my entire family so
supportive like I wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for them and like she she usually
helps with their like with my fashion
I'm in love with fashion 7 so she so she
helps with my makeup what I need to post
when I need a post she just keeps me on
track that's why she moved down here
with me so it's stay on track I didn't
really like start growing until last
year and of like June I've been on that
for like four five years now like social
media in general and it affected a lot
at school school wise no one else had
the app and so like it kind of was weird
that like I was getting to go do like
certain things for like social media
reasons like people didn't not like that
like why are you doing this why I got to
school and so then that's when I like
kind of started to like move towards
like posting like a little less of like
how do you explain that I used to like
post like funny videos and like comedy
make fun of myself and then that would
like backfire but then I finally like
I've gotten over it because like I don't
really care like I'm gonna post it my
sport is like and stuff like that and
then like with posting videos and being
at school and then being a gymnast I was
a gymnast for over ten years I was a
level training level ten gymnast and I
had to quit recently cuz my back but
that's why I started to go on like
online school was because of gymnastics
it was four hours every day at practice
and filming Jake talks and all that so I
kind of like didn't go back into going
to regular school because of like the
whole tick-tock thing and just like I
didn't like emotionally didn't want to
have to deal with it cuz like already
all online that's kind of hard with the
bullying and stuff but having them all
here
help so much did everyone else what
you're going through
[Music]
yes it show their money what nothing
like so we were competing for a level
nine and I stress fractured my back and
then they told me not to compete anymore
if I didn't want to do that so I kept
competing and then I actually like
really really injured it so then I was
like I can't do it anyways
but it got me here I thought listen
Essex I'd be back in the nail I'd like
to be able to like stay on all the apps
and like get to be a part of like all my
supporters and stuff but I also like
really in fashion I want my own clothing
line working on makeup line I'm going
onto YouTube getting into acting it's
kind of just like a bunch of things that
I want to try and do and hopefully they
all work out
[Music]